Anakin spoke highly of you.
have to do what's right,
regardless of our personal feelings.
I bet your master found
you difficult at times,
Anakin never got to finish my training.
I walked away from her
just like I walked away from Sabine.
Ahsoka...Anakin.
I won't leave you.
Not this time.
Then you will die.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
I got a lot of requests
to do in Ahsoka video for her back story
during Star Wars Rebels, The Clone Wars.
This will mostly be
through the lens of her
changing relationship
with an and Skywalker,
and then with him
after he became Darth Vader.
Because there are so many.
And again,
Skywalker references in the trailers.
A lot of you also didn't
watch all the Star Wars Rebels episodes
in the Clone Wars episode.
So I'll explain
the important parts of that.
just in general, though,
Hayden Christensen will be very important
as both Anakin Skywalker
and Darth Vader to the Ahsoka series.
So it's important
to know their backstory together.
why their relationship is so fundamental
to her character and what she's doing
during the Ahsoka episodes
and how it informs her character.
if you're new to the channel,
I'll be doing episode videos for Ahsoka
when it starts.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'll do some special giveaways
during those.
I still got some cool Star Wars stuff
sitting around that I want to give away to
if you did not watch the Clone Wars
or the Star Wars Rebels episodes.
Ahsoka Tano was created
by George Lucas and Dave Filoni
specifically for the Clone Wars.
George Lucas wanted to give and again,
Skywalker Padawan
is someone for younger viewers to follow
because and can they've grown older
like younger people watched
and it can grow up through the prequels
now they wanted another younger character
that people could rally around
he also wanted to give Alnwick
and Skywalker a Padawan
to show his character development.
And even though he hadn't attained
the rank of Jedi master yet
and typically the Council only let Jedi
masters have apprentices.
There were exceptions in the past.
the in-universe reason
why Yoda chose to give Aniket a Padawan
was to alleviate his fears and inability
to let go of loved ones like his mother.
And you had to believe that
by becoming a teacher to Ahsoka,
he would develop emotionally
and understand that his excessive
bonding to those that he cared
about was unnecessary.
Yoda also knew that ultimately Ahsoka would
graduate to the rank of full Jedi Knight
and eventually
leave him to go out on her own.
He hoped that the process
would help Aniket mature.
the reason why it was Ahsoka
Tano in particular that he chose for
this was because of her incredible skill
as a Jedi younglings at the temple.
She was on an accelerated program
and ready to become a Padawan
much sooner than normal.
Just like in a can. Skywalker had been.
also in the background,
the Clone Wars had started
and they needed all the Jedi
they could get in the field.
So Yoda wanted to push Ahsoka
to the next stage in her training
as fast as possible, hoping that
it would also help her mature a little.
Like he believed that both Ahsoka
and Aniket would help each other
become better people and better Jedi.
the only other Jedi master that she'd been
close to up to this point was Pokemon.
He was the one who found her on her home
planet
and brought her into the Jedi Order
as a child.
They covered the events of her early life
during the newer Star
Wars Tales of the Jedi episodes
before Platoon showed up,
she'd also had an encounter
with a rogue former Jedi imposter
pretending to be from the order,
trying to trick her into leaving
so that he could use her
as his own personal weapon.
Ahsoka saw him coming from a mile away,
but developed trust issues because of that
that plagued her until present day.
There very few people that she actually
grows close to, including the characters
during Star Wars
Rebels, which will see a live action
like the crew of the ghost people
like Incan Skywalker.
She eventually became close to Obi-Wan
Kenobi, but still very few people overall.
that's why you see Ahsoka in present day
being such a loner
initially when they first met in Can,
Skywalker didn't have anything to
do with her and just thought of her
as an inconvenience, eventually
going full 180 on her,
both of them growing very close.
Exactly what Yoda did not want to happen.
They both developed very close attachments
to each other.
really hoping we get some snips references
during the series
at some point
she goes on to have all kinds
of adventures
with Anaconda and Obi-Wan Kenobi.
They grow very close to each other.
And then eventually, when she was falsely
accused by the Jedi Council and decided
to leave the order permanently and again,
ultimately
felt like he failed her
and never forgave himself.
she'd also grown close to Obi-Wan Kenobi,
but they didn't have quite
the relationship that she and and can had.
So typically when you see memes
of the clone wars of those characters,
it's usually Obi-Wan Kenobi
scolding Anna in Ahsoka for not listening
to the Jedi Council's orders.
both she and Anakin as characters
just kind of did their own thing,
regardless of orders given to them.
And she's still like that in present day.
the final episodes of The Clone
Wars are amazing.
They were meant to crossover
with Revenge of the Sith,
sort of tie up all those arcs and explain
what happened to everyone.
Buddy during the events of Order 66,
particularly Ahsoka's character,
how did
she escape and how did she react to Annie
Skywalker turning to the dark side
and eventually becoming Darth Vader?
During order 66, she was on her way back
after helping free Mandalore from Darth
Maul in his shadow acolyte.
So she's actually friends with Bo-Katan
Kryze They actually reference
that during Mandalorian season three,
where she told Grogu,
who I've actually known some Jedi
in the past, she was talking about it.
So Caetano.
the events of Antigone's
turn to the dark side happened
while they were in hyperspace.
So the Emperor gives order.
66 all the clones
get It starts going crazy, killing
every Jedi that they can find in a soldier
doesn't know exactly what happened.
But she senses something
terrible happened to the force because
of her connection to Anakin Skywalker.
So she just senses the trauma
that he's going through Eventually,
she blamed herself for not being there
for an occasion when he'd been suffering
all these force visions
about the death of PADMÉ, Luke and Leia.
It was his fear
that ultimately led him to turn
to the dark side and serve the Emperor,
hoping that he would teach him
how to save them, which he did not.
the whole idea is that after
she left the Jedi Order, she broke contact
with and again
until she agreed to help free Mandalore.
so was during that time period
when they were apart that and it concerted
to have those force visions inserted
to go a little bit nuts Ahsoka felt like
had she not left him, had she been there,
she could have prevented
everything that happened.
so she blames herself
for everything that happened too.
And again,
and even though she didn't fully learn
that he become Darth Vader at that point,
the event just completely broke her.
the trauma of all of that
is one of the reasons why she refused to
train Grogu in present day,
even though it seems like she's taken
Sabine Wren as her Padawan finally.
What order 66 was going down.
Some of the clones like Rex, her friends,
were able to resist their programing
or they'd remove their control
chips, explaining
why they're clones during Star Wars
rebels.
Later in the timeline,
they're still friendly with Ahsoka evoked,
a lot of you been asking
and there is a good chance that tomorrow
Morrison will show up in a cameo
at some point as an older version of Rex
there was even a small joke
about this during the Mandalorian season
two, where Boba Fett said that he couldn't
enter the imperial base without a helmet
they'd recognize him
because he's just another clone
and looks exactly like all the others.
Like, Wait a minute,
why is there a clone here? Something's up.
Ahsoka survives order
66 as their ship crashes and leaves
behind her remaining light saber
that Aniket had just given back to her
in order to trick the Empire
into thinking that she died in the crash
to There's a brief time jump.
And then Anakin, who's now fully become
Darth Vader in the armor, finds the crash
site with a bunch of stormtroopers
and her light saber.
So at the time,
he thinks that she died in the crash
in Ahsoka only knew that something terrible
had happened to him.
She doesn't know that.
He also survived Order
66 to become Darth Vader.
So she thinks that Anakin is dead
there used to be a missing time gap
in her timeline.
For several years before the events
of Star Wars rebels pick up.
But they actually just did an Ahsoka book
and then Star Wars Tales
of the Jedi episodes
which cover what she was doing.
she ends up going to ground
hiding out in the outer rim,
kind of doing what you saw Obi-Wan Kenobi
doing at the beginning of the Obi-Wan
series, not using their Jedi abilities,
just trying to hide in the force.
so that the empire in the inquisitors
couldn't find them.
Also, she knew about Darth Vader
but didn't know that Aniket had become
Darth Vader.
She just heard about this Darth Vader
figure going around killing all the Jedi.
she almost winds up getting caught
by an inquisitor, defeats him.
Then Bail
Organa finds her and convinces her
to join the rebellion
and help them take down the empire.
this is still
before the events of Star Wars
and or in before the events of Star Wars.
Rebels.
she takes the secret identity fulcrum
and starts working with the rebellion
as a sort of point of communication
between all the disparate rebel cells.
And she did that up through the events of
Star Wars rebels in the events of Andor.
by the time Star Wars rebels picks up
a few years before a new hope, she starts
openly meeting with the crew of the ghost,
explaining her role as Fulcrum.
They start going on missions together,
even though she doesn't
train Ezra Bridger in the force.
a lot of their missions take them to Jedi
temples and sacred Jedi artifacts.
so she starts to get force
visions of Anakin Skywalker.
Sensing that something happened to him,
he might have survived it,
even though she doesn't get
all the information, does it?
Put everything together.
She starts to get hints that Annacone
might have become Darth Vader.
she starts to grow closer
with the crew of the ghost,
which we're now seeing in live action
during the events of The Mandalorian
and the Ahsoka's series.
she grows closer to Ezra Bridger
and tells him about her own history
as he learns about Anakin
Skywalker, Yoda, the other Jedi.
Eventually, he does wind up meeting
an older version of Obi-Wan Kenobi, too,
but he doesn't reference
Ahsoka, and Ahsoka doesn't reference
older Obi-Wan Kenobi on tattooing.
there's still a lot of questions
about the continuity there.
Like did Obi-Wan Kenobi know that Ahsoka
was still alive when he was on tattooing?
I think the idea is
he was relatively secluded
from what gonna
was doing with Ahsoka in the rebellion.
so he probably did not know about Ahsoka
what she was doing during those years
on tattooing
during the events of Star Wars rebels,
there was a huge Darth Maul Ezra Bridger
arc where Maul begins to try and slowly
bend him to the dark side of the force.
Eventually the inquisitors
track them down to a Sith temple.
Darth Vader learns of their presence
from the inquisitors and arrives
to capture or kill them,
while they're there.
Ahsoka meets Anakin
as Darth Vader in the flesh.
For the first time
since the events of Revenge of the Sith
or before
the events of Revenge of the Sith.
That whole time, all those years,
they hadn't ever actually been
in the same room together,
in at least up to this point.
She hadn't confirmed that Darth Vader
really was in against Skywalker.
Her friend had survived
this is probably one of the best scenes
in all of Star Wars like her just coming
to the realization of what happened.
Like all comes crashing down on her
like a ton of bricks.
later, Ezra winds up saving her,
using the world between worlds
and some Jedi time travel trickery,
explaining how she missed a few years
in the timeline during Rebels.
But during the events
of the original trilogy,
she stayed in the outer rim, relatively
continuing to act in a role as Fulcrum,
helping the rebels as much as possible.
this is sort of the way that Dave Filoni
explains why she wasn't around
during the original Star Wars movies
or during the prequels either.
For a little while,
they talked about this little girl
being Ahsoka,
but the timeline isn't right.
Ahsoka's a little bit older
when this scene is happening
in Attack of the Clones,
so this could not be her.
You have to remember
she wasn't created as a character.
Like they didn't come up with the idea
for Ahsoka till after Revenge of the Sith
that come out in theaters.
but up to present day
at least canonically.
During the events of the original trilogy.
She never met Luke or Leia,
but once she heard about the hotshot pilot
who blew up the Death Star,
who's calling himself Luke Skywalker,
she instantly realized who it was in
the manikins children had survived.
as far as Dave
Filoni has explained, up to present day.
She didn't actually meet Luke Skywalker
in the flesh until after the events
of Return of the Jedi when he started
to create his Jedi Academy on Austin.
So that's the planet that this is on
her scenes with Luke Skywalker
during the book of Boba
Fett happened after her cameo seen
during The Mandalorian Season two,
we might see
Luke Skywalker cameo during the saga,
or they'll reference him in some way
because there are so many innocent
Skywalker references in the trailer.
Now in present day.
During the new episode,
she's finally taken on Sabine
Wren as a Padawan,
but talks about how her trauma over
and can Skywalker caused her to leave
as her master for a time
Then at some point during the series
she runs into battle in school,
in the trailers, we see that, he says
he knew Anakin when they were both Jedi.
Part of the order
and told him about Ahsoka.
really easy prediction
to make that they're
including all these anarchist references
to set up a Hayden Christensen cameo scene
as force goes in again, Skywalker
maybe another flashback to young Ahsoka
during the Clone Wars.
Maybe he'll also have a cameo seen
as Darth Vader
in some kind of flashback to their rematch
fight in the Sith Temple.
one of the reasons why an account
is so important to the series is
to show how she's following the force
in a completely different way
than the old Jedi Order in how she chooses
to act as Jedi master to Sabine Wren.
really hoping that force goes.
And again, Skywalker shows up
to give her a pep talk at some point
in what it means to be a teacher.
Now that things have come full circle
for her to make a Darth Vader reference.
She was once the learner.
Now she is the master
and she has to go through everything
that Anna-Kat went through with her
when she was younger
Because the way they're playing
their relationship,
being kind of tense is kind of
the relationship between Ahsoka and Anakin.
And back in the Clone Wars,
when she first became his Padawan
as far as I remember, force goes Anakin
Skywalker has never actually appeared
to Ahsoka before or spoken to her
after his death, so this would technically
be their first reunion since that since
Temple fight during Star Wars Rebels.
she would have eventually learned
about his redemption
and what he did
trying to kill the emperor.
She believes that he succeeded too,
because remember,
they don't know that the emperor survived.
So hopefully that just explains
a little bit about her timeline
during the Clone Wars, Star Wars
rebels in why her relationship with
and again Skywalker is so special
to the new Ahsoka episodes.
if you want to watch Star Wars Rebels
or The Clone Wars and you didn't before,
you don't need to watch
every single episode.
I would just recommend,
like the last season of rebels
in some of the final arc of Star
Wars, the Clone Wars
there's also this whole long relationship
that Ahsoka has with Grand Admiral Thrawn
going back to Star Wars rebels.
I'll talk
more about that in a separate video.
Otherwise this would turn into
like a four hour video
there's so much history
between all the different characters.
That goes way back to the Clone
Wars. It's super deep.
We'll talk about it
during my Ahsoka episodes.
When that starts.
Is that character show up?
there are a lot of characters
that they did
not include in the Ahsoka trailer,
so they'll be some big surprises
during the series.
generally expect all the big Star Wars
rebels characters to appear
during the episodes at some point.
Let me know if you have any big questions
about the characters
just in general or any video requests,
click here for My New Mandalorian Season
four video and learn
what's going on with the live action
caucuses.
And click here for that brand new Ahsoka
trailer with a whole bunch of Easter eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.